Some would say that we're in
a post-feminist era because they
hope it will go away.
[LAUGHS]
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
We are the revolution
that is going
to see to it that
no one is ever born
into an inferior role again
because of race or of sex.
The feminist is someone who
believes in the full humanity
of all people.
That's it.
Every single
individual on the planet
deserves the same
sovereignty over their being.
And when you see that,
it changes your worldview
on everything.
There's a long
history of people
taking their painful
living truths
and channeling
that into justice.
So we've never had an
attitude, a cultural response
here in the United States, that
said, caregiving is actually
in the public interest.
To watch this class, you
don't need to be a woman.
You don't have to
be an activist.
Feminism is open for
everyone, and it's
a way of challenging a
division that should not exist.
[CROWD CHANTING]
Justice is different
for different people.
In some states, survivors are
charged for their rape kits.
It's such a
painful waste of time
to fight so hard
to be ourselves.
The change comes
from the bottom up.
It's the whole nature of
even democracy itself.
Whether you're talking about
abortion rights, violence
against women, or caregiving,
all leads you to that place.
What is the world we
really want to have?
I'm Amanda Nguyen.
I'm Tina Tchen.
I'm adrienne maree brown.
I'm Gloria Steinem.
ALL: And this is MasterClass.
[UPBEAT MUSIC]